la carga eléctrica cum es una propiedad
que tienen algunas pero no todas las
partículas en la naturaleza las
partículas fundamentales cargadas de las
que más comúnmente se hablan son los
electrones los cuales orbitan al
exterior del átomo estos electrones
están cargados negativamente también por
acá tenemos a los protones los cuales
tienen una carga positiva y también
tenemos al 2 neutrones los cuales tienen
una carga neutra no son positivos ni
negativos no tienen carga alguna y tanto
los protones como los neutrones están
dentro del núcleo del átomo y resulta
que todas las partículas
fundamentalmente cargadas en el universo
tienen cargas que vienen en unidades
enteras de esta carga elemental así que
si encuentras una partícula en la
naturaleza va a tener la carga de uno
por este número o dos por este número o
tres por este número
etcétera y bueno podría ser positiva o
negativa por ejemplo el electrón tiene
una carga de menos 1.6 por 10 menos 19
coloms el protón tiene una carga de más
1.6 por 10 a las 19 con la oms etcétera
sin embargo la mayoría de los átomos son
eléctricamente neutros eso quiere decir
que tendrán tantos electrones como
protones en el átomo pero si un átomo
tuviera demasiados electrones en general
ese átomo estaría cargado negativamente
y si un átomo tuviera muy pocos
electrones en general ese átomo estaría
cargado positivamente algo que es
realmente importante recordar es que la
carga eléctrica es conservativa siempre
se conserva para cada proceso en otras
palabras la carga total inicial va a ser
igual a la carga total final después de
cualquier proceso y que hagamos un
problema que involucre a la carga
eléctrica
esferas de metal del mismo tamaño
comienzan con las cargas que se muestran
a continuación así que aquí la tenemos
la esfera x comienza con una carga de 5
con la esfera y james empieza con una
carga de 3com y la esfera zeta empieza
con una carga de menos 2 q
si tocas la esfera x con la esfera y
después las separas y a continuación
toca la esfera y james con la esfera
zeta
después las separadas cuál será la carga
final de cada esfera bien primero si
tocamos la esfera x con la esfera gem
entonces qué es lo que va a pasar
bueno observa lo siguiente hay una carga
total de 8 q entre ellas y ya que son de
tamaño idéntico ambas van a compartir la
carga total lo que significa que después
de tocarse están tendrá una carga de 4
un positivo y esta también va a tener
una carga de 4 positivo eso porque las
dos son del mismo tamaño si una de las
esferas fuera más grande que la otra
ganaría más la carga pero al final la
carga total sigue conservándose y si
después tocas
era james con la esfera zeta que es lo
que va a pasar
bueno aquí tenemos cuatro cum y aquí hay
menos dos q y como van a compartir la
carga por igual entonces ésta va a
quedar con una carga de cum de q
positiva y esta también va a quedar con
una carga de q positiva así que si
observamos las respuestas
vemos que la se cumple eso carga
supuestas atraen y cargas iguales se
repelen y lo que la ley de coloma hace
es darte una manera para encontrar la
magnitud de la fuerza eléctrica entre
dos cargas y la fórmula para ver esta
fuerza va a ser la siguiente lo que nos
dice la ley de coulón es que la magnitud
de la fuerza eléctrica que se ejerce
entre dos cargas va a ser igual a camps
que es una constante la cual es igual a
9 x 19 newtons metros cuadrados entre
colomos cuadrados ya esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por el producto de m
dos cargas de estas dos cargas las
cuales van a ser medidas en colomos
nkoulou y esto será dividido por la
distancia que hay de centro al centro de
las dos cargas elevada al cuadrado y ojo
no olvides elevar esta distancia al
cuadrado de hecho esta distancia se debe
dar en metros si quieres encontrar las
unidades en el sistema internacional de
newtons para la fuerza además una cosa
que es importante es que esta fórmula de
aquí no se va a hacer los signos
negativos o positivos que tengan las
cargas para decirte en qué dirección
apuntan las fuerzas porque sólo se usa
el hecho de que las cargas opuestas
atraen y que las cargas iguales se
repelen y usamos la ley de coulón para
obtener la magnitud de la fuerza ahora
vamos a hacer un problema que involucra
a la ley de colom dos cargas ejercen una
sobre la otra una fuerza eléctrica de
magnitud f
cuál será la magnitud de la nueva fuerza
si tomamos el triple de la distancia
entre ellas y el doble de la magnitud de
una de las cargas bien así que primero
vamos a recordar qué es lo que nos dice
la ley de colom la ley de colom nos dice
que la fuerza entre dos cargas
eléctricas va a ser igual a la constante
camps que multiplica a q1 por q 2 muy
bien esto dividido entre la distancia al
cuadrado esto dividido entre la
distancia elevada al cuadrado y ahora si
queremos encontrar la fuerza nueva la
fuerza nueva ésta va a ser igual a bueno
la constante k que multiplican a q1 y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es duplicar una
de las fuerzas así que lo voy a poner
así 2 que multiplica a q2 ya esto lo voy
a dividir en tres y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en el triple de la distancia
entre ellas
distancia original que teníamos y bueno
a esto hay que elevarlo al cuadrado
ahora si observas por aquí tenemos un
factor de 2 y por acá abajo obtenemos un
factor de 3 elevado al cuadrado ojo este
3 lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado por lo
tanto vamos a tener un factor de dos
novenos de dos novenos que multiplica
quien bueno multiplican acá que
multiplica su vez aquí uno que
multiplica a su vez a q2 ya esto lo
tenemos dividido entre la distancia
elevado al cuadrado pero si observas
esta cantidad que tengo aquí esto que
tengo aquí es exactamente lo mismo que
la fuerza original así que la magnitud
de la nueva fuerza va a ser lo mismo que
la magnitud de la fuerza anterior
multiplicado por un factor de dos
novenos eso nos da esta respuesta ven
la corriente eléctrica y nos dice la
cantidad de columnas de carga que pasan
por un punto en un segundo dado así que
si observas en un punto en el cable y
cuentas cuántos colom se están pasando
por este cable en ese segundo eso sería
la corriente eléctrica y si queremos ver
esto como una fórmula podemos ver que la
corriente eléctrica es lo mismo que la
carga que pasan por el punto pm en un
tiempo t y estos nos dan unidades de
coulón entre segundos y lo podemos
abreviar como amper y ya que la carga y
el tiempo no son vectores entonces la
corriente eléctrica no es un vector y
algo que es un poco extraño es la
dirección convencional de la corriente
esta es la dirección en la que fluye la
carga positiva sin embargo las cargas
positivas no fluyen en un cable las
únicas cargas que realmente fluyen son
las cargas negativas estas de aquí
entonces si decimos que las cargas
eléctricas negativas están fluyendo
hacia la izquierda
es físicamente lo mismo que las cargas
positivas fluyan hacia la derecha así
que en la mayoría de los problemas de
física pretendemos como si fueran las
cargas positivas las que se mueven sin
embargo son realmente los electrones que
son negativos los que se están moviendo
dentro del cable y si te preguntas cómo
se ve un problema de la corriente
eléctrica
ahora vamos a resolver uno una corriente
de 3 amperes fluyen en un cierto
circuito cuánta carga pasa por un cierto
punto en el circuito en un lapso de 5
minutos
así que recordemos la corriente
eléctrica la acabamos de definir como la
cantidad de carga que pasa en un tiempo
dado muy bien pero ya tenemos la
corriente eléctrica así que si queremos
despejar de que la carga nos va a quedar
que la carga es lo mismo que la
corriente eléctrica que multiplica al
tiempo muy bien así que en este caso la
carga va a ser igual a la corriente
eléctrica que es lo mismo que 3 amperes
3 amperes
y multiplican al tiempo pero ojo el
tiempo no lo podemos dar en minutos lo
tenemos que dar en segundos para así
obtener con la oms entonces voy a tener
cinco minutos minutos que multiplican a
60 segundos esto por cada minuto y bueno
a cuánto va a ser igual
todo esto esto va a ser igual a 900 900
go la oms esta es mi respuesta que es la
de la resistencia miden qué tanto supone
un resistor o una resistencia al flujo
de la corriente eléctrica eso quiere
decir que entre más grande sea la
resistencia o el registro menor
corriente dejará fluir y la definición
de resistencia se basa en la ley d
la ley de ohm dice que la cantidad de
corriente eléctrica es proporcional al
voltaje y es inversamente proporcional a
la resistencia así que entre estos dos
puntos que tengo aquí la corriente que
va a fluir va a ser igual al voltaje
entre la resistencia que hay entre esos
dos puntos así que entre mayor sea la
resistencia menor corriente eléctrica va
a ser la que fluya y entre más voltaje
tengas mayor corriente eléctrica va a
ser la que tengamos y esto es lo que nos
dice la ley de ohm incluso la ley de ohm
te puede dar una forma de definir la
resistencia pero también puedes
determinar la resistencia de un elemento
de un circuito de un resistor conociendo
el tamaño y la forma de ese resistor en
otras palabras la resistencia de este
resistor va a ser igual a esta rom
la resistividad y esta resistividad es
una resistencia natural que tienen a la
corriente esto multiplicado por el largo
de este resistor es decir entre más
largo sea este resistor mayor
resistencia vas a tener y entre más
corto sea este resistor menor
resistencia vas a tener y esto dividido
entre el área del resistor la cual es
esta sección transversal que tenemos
aquí y bueno la corriente puede estar
fluyendo dentro o fuera de este resistor
y si el resistor es un cilindro entonces
el área de este círculo va a ser pi por
el radio elevado al cuadrado y las
unidades de la resistencia son los oms
esto que tenemos aquí y bueno no es un
vector de hecho la resistencia siempre
va a ser positiva o en su dado caso 0 y
como se ve un problema que involucre la
ley de ohm o en su dado caso la
resistencia de un resistor cilíndrico
bueno veamos el siguiente problema
cuando una batería de voltaje bm se
conecta a un resistor cilíndrico simple
de longitud l y de radio r fluye una
corriente eléctrica
a través de la batería cuál es la
resistividad del resistor y ojo la
resistividad rom del resistor bueno para
eso primero vamos a usar la ley de ohm
la ley d hondt dice que la intensidad de
corriente eléctrica es igual al cambio
en el voltaje entre la resistencia y si
de aquí despejamos la resistencia vamos
a obtener que la resistencia es
exactamente lo mismo que el cambio en el
voltaje esto dividido a su vez entre la
corriente eléctrica pero por otra parte
acabamos de ver que la resistencia
resistor cilíndrico es lo mismo que ron
que es la resistividad que multiplica al
largo de este resistor entre el área
transversal muy bien y si ahora utilizo
esto para ponerlo justo aquí me va a
quedar lo siguiente me va a quedar que
rompe que multiplica al largo esto
dividido entre el ancho va a ser igual
al cambio en el voltaje entre la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica ahora
de aquí podemos despejar arrom rom va a
ser igual a el voltaje por el área
transversal esto dividido a su vez por
la corriente eléctrica por el largo la
corriente eléctrica por el largo pero
sabemos que el área
un resistor cilíndrico va a ser igual a
pin por el radio elevado al cuadrado así
que voy a utilizar esta información de
aquí para meterlo justo acá y entonces
me va a quedar que ro es decir la
resistividad va a ser igual al voltaje
que multiplica a pin que multiplica al
radio elevado al cuadrado
todo esto dividido entre la corriente
eléctrica que multiplica a l y si
observas es justo la respuesta hace
ahora bien cuando tratamos con circuitos
complicados con mucho resistor es muchas
veces debe reducir esos resistor es a
una menor cantidad de resistor es que
sea equivalente y las dos maneras que
haces esto es encontrando resistor es
que estén en serie o resistor es que
estén en paralelo ahora bien si hablamos
de resistor es que están en serie estos
van a tener la misma corriente eléctrica
la misma corriente eléctrica que fluye
por ellos si la corriente eléctrica se
ramificará se ramificará algo más o
menos así entonces no estaríamos
hablando de resistor es en serie si
estamos hablando de resistor es en serie
lo que quiero que veas es que el
resistor equivalente va a ser igual a la
suma de los otros dos resistor es así
que la corriente para resistor es en
serie es la misma pero el voltaje podría
ser distinto porque tenemos diferentes
resistencias ahora bien si hablamos de
resistor es que están en paralelo
entonces la corriente va a entrar y
después se va a dividir para cada uno de
los receptores para este resistor y para
este resistor y después la corriente se
vuelve a unir en este punto para seguir
a cualquier otra cosa del circuito y si
este es el caso puedes encontrar la
resistencia equivalente entre estos dos
puntos entre este punto de kim y este
punto de acá o dicho otra manera entre
esta porción de
entre esta porción del circuito vas a
encontrar esta resistencia equivalente
simplemente sumando 1 entre la primera
resistencia más 1 entre la segunda
resistencia pero ten cuidado 1 entre la
resistencia 1 más 1 entre la resistencia
2 te va a dar 1 entre la resistencia
equivalente si quieres obtener la
resistencia equivalente vas a tener que
tomar de recíproco de esto o tomarte la
división de 1 entre esta cantidad que
tengo aquí ahora bien trabajamos con un
problema que tenga que ver con
resistencias en serie o en paralelo
considera el circuito que se muestra a
continuación y tenemos este circuito de
aquí cuál es la corriente eléctrica que
fluye a través de la resistencia de 8
oms ok y bueno puedes estar tentado a
tomarte la ley de ohm y decir la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica es
igual al cambio en el voltaje está
dividido entre la resistencia y ya
porque el voltaje es 24 volts ya esto lo
voy a dividir entre la resistencia que
son 8 oms y bueno esto me va a dar 3
amperes y ya está pero qué creés esto no
está del todo bien porque es lo que dice
la ley de ohm es que la intensidad de
corriente eléctrica que vamos a aplicar
a un cierto resistor va a ser igual al
voltaje que llega a ese resistor entre
la resistencia que tiene así que si
introducimos este resistor de ocho oms
habrá que fijarnos en cuál es el voltaje
que le llega porque ojo no va a ser este
voltaje de 24 volts completos en otras
palabras la batería provee un voltaje
entre este punto y en este punto que
tengo aquí porque también va a haber una
caída de voltaje a través de las
resistencias de m6 oms y 12 oms por lo
tanto la cantidad de voltaje que va a
llegar a 8 oms es menor
y qué te parece si reducimos estas
resistencias a una sola resistencia lo
primero que vamos a hacer es fijarnos en
estas dos resistencias que se observan
están en paralelo aquí se divide la
intensidad de corriente eléctrica y
después llega de nuevo a este punto de
aquí entonces como estas dos están en
paralelo voy a decir que 1 entre esta
resistencia que estoy buscando estas dos
va a ser igual a 1 entre 6 más 1 entre
12 y esto va a ser igual a am bueno
un sexto más un doceavo son 3 doceavos
que es lo mismo que un cuarto o dicho de
otra manera
estas dos resistencias las puede reducir
en esta resistencia de color verde que
es de 4 o
así que entre este punto de aquí y este
punto de aquí tenemos una resistencia de
cuatro ojos observa que esta resistencia
que tengo aquí está en serie con esta
otra resistencia por lo tanto la
resistencia total va a ser igual a la
suma de 8 oms más estos 4 ops por lo
tanto esto va a ser igual a bueno
84 son 12 oms
esa es la resistencia total de este
circuito que tengo aquí así que ahora
puedo decir que todo este circuito de
aquí se puede reducir a un circuito que
tiene solamente una resistencia de 12 ó
12 oms y bueno teníamos un voltaje de 24
volts y ahora sí puedo quitar esta parte
de aquí y este resultado que no está
bien y la corriente que fluye a través
de esta batería lo cual va a ser bueno
la división de esto que es 2 amperes y
si observas este resistor de 8 oms está
en serie con esta batería por lo tanto
tiene la misma intensidad de corriente
los elementos de un circuito muchas
veces usan potencia eléctrica es decir
cuando la corriente eléctrica fluye a
través de un resistor los electrones
cambian su energía potencial
electrostática a otros tipos de energía
como calor luz y sonido
la tasa a la cual los electrones cambian
su energía a otra forma de energía es lo
que se conoce como potencia eléctrica
así que la tasa en la cual un resistor
está convirtiendo energía eléctrica en
calor es la potencia eléctrica utilizada
por esa resistencia en otras palabras a
la cantidad de energía que fluye en un
cierto tiempo a esto le llamamos
potencia recuerdas pero ahora podemos
ver esta misma potencia a este número de
jules por segundo en términos de
cantidades como la corriente eléctrica
el voltaje y la resistencia así que la
potencia utilizada por un resistor lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
una primera forma de escribirlo como la
corriente eléctrica que multiplica al
voltaje pero si usamos la ley de ohm y
sustituimos este valor de aquí podemos
encontrarnos con que la potencia
eléctrica es igual a la corriente
eléctrica elevada al cuadrado por la
resistencia del resistor
bueno también podemos reorganizar estas
fórmulas para obtener que la potencia es
igual a el voltaje elevado al cuadrado
dividido entre la resistencia del
resistor es decir estas tres te deben de
dar la misma potencia si las utilizas de
manera correcta y si quieres determinar
el número de jules de energía que da esa
potencia bueno recuerda que esto es lo
mismo que la energía dividido entre el
tiempo de aquí podría despejar a la
energía ahora bien las unidades de la
potencia eléctrica son las mismas
unidades que tienes en la potencia los
watts o el 'you'll de entre segundo y
bueno la potencia eléctrica no es un
vector así que si te preguntas cómo se
ve en un problema que tiene que ver con
potencia eléctrica podemos resolver el
siguiente dicen un foco de resistencia r
se conecta a una fuente de voltaje en un
segundo foco de resistencia 12 m se
conecta a otra fuente de voltaje 2 b
se está duplicando la resistencia y el
voltaje como podemos comparar el
potencial generado por el segundo foco
en comparación con el potencial generado
por el primer foco y bueno ya que
tenemos la información de la resistencia
y el voltaje vamos a utilizar la fórmula
para la potencia eléctrica que dice que
la potencia eléctrica es igual a la
diferencia en el voltaje esto elevado al
cuadrado y dividido entre r que en el
caso del primer foco esto va a ser igual
al voltaje elevado al cuadrado dividido
entre r hasta aquí vamos bien pero a
nuestro segundo foco le va a pasar lo
siguiente vamos a agarrar el voltaje y
lo vamos a duplicar así que tenemos dos
veces este mismo voltaje este mismo
voltaje déjame cerrar esto y lo voy a
elevar al cuadrado y también dicen que
tenemos el doble de la resistencia que
teníamos en el foco original así que me
voy a tomar
dos veces la resistencia que teníamos
inicialmente
y bueno si le vas a esto al cuadrado me
va a quedar esto es lo mismo que cuatro
veces b cuadrada b cuadrada ok esto
dividido su vez entre bueno 22 veces r
ahora observamos que nuestro factor es
cuatro medios que es lo mismo que 2 esto
es exactamente lo mismo que 2 que
multiplican am b cuadrado entre r pero
esto de aquí esto de aquí era la
potencia eléctrica que teníamos
originalmente era esto de aquí por lo
tanto el segundo foco va a tener un
factor de 2 en la potencia eléctrica eso
quiere decir que el foco con
resistencias 2rm tienen el doble de
potencial estamos hablando del inciso a
y eso significa que el foco va a ser más
brillante la cantidad que determina el
brillo del foco es la potencia eléctrica
de ese foco no es necesariamente la
resistencia o el voltaje es la
combinación de los dos en esta fórmula
esta fórmula con la que empezamos o en
las otras fórmulas podemos obtener la
potencia eléctrica de cada
por lo tanto la potencia eléctrica te va
a indicar el brillo del foco dos ideas
muy útiles son las leyes de chirico y la
primera es la ley de nodos y dicen toda
la corriente que entra a un nodo es
igual a toda la corriente que sale del
nodo y lo puedes ver aquí toda la
corriente que entra es igual a toda la
corriente que sale y es que estos se
basan en el principio de la conservación
de la carga en otras palabras si sumas
toda la corriente que fluye en uno doble
está debe ser igual a toda la corriente
que sale del nodo porque la carga se
conserva así que la carga no puede ser
creada ni destruida en cualquier punto
del circuito de igual manera que el agua
no puede ser creada ni destruida dentro
de una serie de tuberías y la segunda
ley es la ley de lazos dicen si sumas
todas las cargas del potencial eléctrico
el voltaje en un lazo cerrado de un
circuito eléctrico
el resultado será igual a cero y bueno
esta ley se basa en el principio de la
conservación de la energía
ver aquí así que si sumas todos los
voltajes encontrados a través de un lazo
cerrado a través del circuito siempre
sumar a 0 los electrones van a ganar
energía y van a perder energía cuando
entren en una resistencia sin embargo la
cantidad total de energía que ganan en
la batería debe de ser igual a la
cantidad total de energía que pierden
debido a las resistencias en otras
palabras si consideramos un circuito
complicado que tengan una batería y tres
resistencias entonces la corriente total
fluyendo en un nodo por ejemplo aquí
tenemos el nodo y uno debe de ser igual
a la corriente total saliendo de este
nodo es decir y 2 e iu 3 ya que ninguna
carga es creada destruida y eso
significa que cuando estas dos
corrientes se combinan de nuevo justo
aquí se combinan de nuevo la corriente
total fluyendo fuera de esta sección
será de nuevo
por aquí tenemos que pasar la corriente
y
y si seguimos un nodo cercano a través
de este circuito la suma de todos los
voltajes debe de ser igual a 0 es decir
el voltaje de la batería menos el
voltaje del primer registro menos el
voltaje del segundo resistor esto nos
tiene que dar igual a cero así que si te
preguntas cómo se ve un problema que
involucre en lo que estamos aprendiendo
con las leyes de kirchhoff podemos ver
el siguiente problema dicen considera el
circuito que se muestra a continuación
cuál es el voltaje a través de la
resistencia de 6 oms para esto voy a
usar la ley de lazos así que si
empezamos detrás de esta batería y
hacemos un lazo que atrapen esta
resistencia de la cual queremos saber su
voltaje entonces me va a quedar algo más
o menos así este va a ser mi lazo y
bueno recuerda que lo que queremos es el
voltaje de esta resistencia de 6 oms
ahora también sabemos que si sumamos
todos los voltajes a través de este lazo
debe de ser igual a cero déjame notarlo
la suma de todos los voltajes que hay en
este lazo tiene que ser igual a cero así
que si nos fijamos empezamos con un
voltaje de 24 volts un voltaje de 24
volts esto es lo que nos da la batería
ya esto le voy a quitar primero el
voltaje que hay en estos 6 oms ok y
también le voy a quitar el voltaje que
hay en esta otra resistencia de 82 ahora
lo padre de esto es que podemos calcular
cuál es el voltaje que pasa por esta
resistencia de 8 oms porque sabemos que
por ella pasan 2 amperes entonces sí
recuerdo que el voltaje es igual a la
corriente que multiplica a la
resistencia esto por la ley de ohm
entonces puedo decir que el voltaje en
esta resistencia de 8 oms va a ser igual
a 2 amperes que multiplican
homs y bueno esto me dan 16 volts
entonces ahora que tengo esta cantidad
ya puedo utilizarla en mi problema voy a
tratar esto de aquí y lo voy a prender
justo acá y entonces me va a quedar que
24 volts 24 volts menos este voltaje en
la resistencia que estamos buscando el
voltaje en la resistencia de 6 oms -
menos 16 volts esto tiene que ser igual
a cero
o dicho de otra manera si ya despejamos
este voltaje el voltaje de la
resistencia de 6 oms va a ser lo mismo
que 24 volts menos 16 volts lo cual es
igual a 8 volts de lujo ya puedo decir
que mi respuesta es la ve y ojo ya que
la resistencia de 12 oms y la de 6 oms
están en paralelo el voltaje a través de
la resistencia de 12 oms también va a
ser de 8 volts así que este voltaje
también va a ser de 8 volts el voltaje a
través de cualquiera de dos elementos en
paralelo tiene que ser el mismo
-los voltímetros son dispositivos que
miden el voltaje entre dos puntos los
voltímetros deben estar conectados en
paralelo en paralelo con los dos puntos
así el voltímetro puede medir el voltaje
de manera correcta en otras palabras
para medir el voltaje de r3 lo que vamos
a hacer es conectar los dos
puntos del voltímetro justo aquí esto
nos dará el voltaje a través de r 3 y
bueno el multímetro observa que está
conectado en paralelo está conectado en
paralelo por otra parte los perímetros
son dispositivos que miden la corriente
que pasan a través de un punto en un
circuito los amperímetro se deben de
estar conectados en serie en serie con
los dos puntos a medir así la corriente
puede fluir de manera adecuada a través
del amperímetro así que si queremos
medir cuánta corriente fluyen a través
de r1 tenemos que conectar a este
amperímetro amd en serie con uno noten
que para que estos aparatos funcionen
bien los amperímetro se deben de tener
una resistencia interna de casi cero y
esto es porque de este modo no van a
afectar a la corriente que fluye a
través del circuito y por otra parte los
voltímetros deben de tener una
resistencia interna casi infinita así no
igualarían ninguna de las corrientes de
la resistencia que estén
dando por ellos en realidad los
amperímetro tienen una resistencia
interna muy pequeña pero distrito de
cero y los multímetros tienen una
resistencia muy alta pero no infinita y
bueno si te preguntas cómo se ve un
problema que involucra amperímetro si
multímetros podemos ver el siguiente
considera el circuito que se muestra a
continuación este de aquí si los
círculos numerados son voltímetros
multímetros cuáles de ellos nos dan el
voltaje correcto que pasan a través del
resistor de ocho oms seleccionan las dos
respuestas correctas y deben ser
cuidadosos porque algunos problemas de
apem van a requerir la selección de dos
respuestas correctas cuando tenemos una
opción múltiple así que asegúrate de
leer cuidadosamente las instrucciones
bien lo primero que veo es que el
voltímetro 4 es una terrible opción
nunca conectes tu volt y metro en serie
con el elemento al cual quieres medir tu
voltaje así que ésta
no es la opción correcta ahora si me
fijo en el número uno en este de aquí y
observa que estoy midiendo el voltaje
entre dos puntos donde adentro no hay
nada solamente cable en medio de estos
dos puntos así que el voltaje medido por
el voltímetro número uno va a ser
exactamente igual que es cero ya que el
voltaje a través de un cable de
resistencia a cero debe darte cero volts
por lo tanto la opción correcta no es la
1 así que puedo tachar también está y
bueno las opciones correctas van a ser
el número 2 y el número 3 el número 2 te
da el voltaje a través de la resistencia
de 8 oms observan que la resistencia de
8 mbps está adentro de estos dos puntos
y también el voltímetro 3 porque si
observas esta resistencia de 8 oms
también está dentro de estos 2